there is a dangerous creature that could
be anywhere in the world hiding in plain
sight casually walking through crowded
streets filled with people a monster
that is nearly impossible to see
blending into its surroundings almost
perfectly not invisible but unnoticeable
almost completely undetectable but then
you spot a familiar outfit in a crowd
you now know where the creature is but
it goes both ways
since the moment you find it it knows
where you are there is now not a single
place on the earth that you could hide
where it wouldn't find you and it won't
ever stop looking to the staff at the
foundation this creature is known as
scp-4885
but you and i know him by a different
name you may have seen his face hundreds
of times or stared for hours at a page
trying to catch a glimpse of him to us
he's waldo while this might feel like a
very long-winded and silly joke maybe
even a prank that has been inserted into
the scp archives it is anything but if
you grew up any time after the late
1980s then you will likely be familiar
with the where's waldo books but for the
uninitiated there are a series of puzzle
books created by illustrator martin
hanford each book in the where's waldo
line contains multiple double page
spreads of colorful crowded scenes the
goal is for readers to spot the ever
elusive titular character waldow who is
hidden among the mass of other
characters waldo himself is easily
recognized
thanks to a design that has become truly
iconic over the years he is always
depicted as wearing a red and white
striped shirt with a bobble hat in
matching colors waldo also sports jeans
circular rimmed glasses and sometimes a
wooden walking stick so with that
important context out of the way up
front what exactly is scp-4885
is the character from these children's
books somehow brought to life has the
character of waldo always been a
malicious malevolent entity too powerful
to be contained within his own books
well not exactly scp-4885
only seems to resemble the famous
children's book character whether or not
he is the living manifestation of waldo
in the real world is both unclear and up
for debate examining its outward
appearance
scp-4885 does share the humanoid shape
and looks to be wearing the same
recognizable clothing of waldo there are
however two notable bodily
dissimilarities between the waldo on the
page and the physical form of scp-4885
for one this waldo appears to be much
paler to the one found in the book
series
more noticeably however is the fact
despite wearing the same circular
glasses scp-4885
seems to have no eyes should a person
learn of
scp-4885's current location waldo will
simultaneously gain an awareness of this
person learning instantly of their
victim's location
scp-4885 will traverse any space
necessary tracking their target down to
anywhere they might be in the world the
creatures displayed a number of
space-altering abilities including
teleportation
scp-4885 can also alter the state of his
own matter allowing waldo to phase
through solid surfaces no obstacle can
stop his advance not walls not buildings
not even his victim's own body when
scp-4885
finally reaches the person who has
learned of his location waldo will then
proceed to murder them in an
exceptionally excruciating manner using
his matter-changing abilities he will
teleport or face himself inside his
victim pulling himself through their
body and destroying their internal
organs after causing catastrophic bodily
damage
scp-4885 will then wrench their victim's
jaw open unhinging it with enough force
to climb his way out of their mouth
leaving them dead their body completely
mangled however this isn't even the
final stage of waldo's attack there is a
strange byproduct left after a fatal
encounter with scp-4885
a yellow liquid that is produced as
waldo exits his victim's body when this
substance comes into contact with the
deceased person's skin it triggers a
bizarre change the liquid will cause
their bodies to change after death their
skin becoming covered in cymbals on
closer inspection it becomes clear that
these symbols are illustrations
exactly like the ones found in the pages
of where's waldo these corpses referred
to by the foundation as instances of
scp-4885-a
will then start to act in a similar
manner to scp-4885
and anyone who sees one or learns of its
location will cause waldo to come
looking for them the where's waldo
scenes left on a deceased victim's skin
cannot be washed off or otherwise
removed and the only way to undo an
instance of
scp-4885-1 is to skin an infected body
after death however this creates a whole
new problem if someone was to attempt
this in doing so they would know the
location of one of waldo's victims this
knowledge would mean that whoever was
trying to skin one of these bodies would
themselves become waldo's next target
and would likely end up just another
instance of scp-4885-1
in other words it would be an exercise
in futility naturally the nature of
visibilities and attack patterns make it
difficult for the scp foundation to
contain waldo
scp-4885 cannot be harmed through the
use of firearms or other common
conventional weapons at the foundation's
disposal you might be forgiven for
thinking that making a handful of people
aware of where to find waldo at the same
time would be a viable solution after
all he cannot be in multiple places at
once so perhaps he'd be unable to kill
these individuals simultaneously however
scp-4885 has shown to be able to cope
with this approach
dispatching his victims one at a time
transforming each in turn into where's
waldo printed corpses before continuing
to the next would-be victim if the
victim is nearby waldow will force
himself into their mouth passing through
their body and destroying bones organs
and even the spinal column when his
victim is further away waldo will phase
through the nearest wall and attack them
teleporting into his target and then
climbing out of their mouth while those
location or that of his victims bodies
are considered info hazards simply being
aware of this information will cause
scp-4885 to activate as a result of this
the staff at the scp foundation are not
even sure that waldo is actually
contained at all in theory
scp-4885 is being held at an undisclosed
foundation site within a non-designed
containment chamber since even a number
on the door would tip off what's inside
triggering waldo's abilities but here's
the clincher because nobody can know for
sure where waldo is without him coming
for him nobody at the foundation
actually knows where he's being
contained if he's even contained at all
it is worth noting that if someone
receives a vague non-specific
description of waldo's whereabouts that
he will make no attempt to seek them out
if he is contained and if he was to ever
breach containment then the scp
foundation has an entire set of
procedures in place to ensure that no
one ever finds waldo first 36
containment chambers identical to the
one
scp-4885 is supposedly held in are
connected to a self-driving vehicle an
expendable d-class personnel member is
placed into the vehicle and a random
number generator will select a number
from 1 to 36 the self-driving vehicle
will then arrive at the containment
chamber chosen at random and the d-class
placed inside within each chamber are
digital monitors and once the d-class is
inside the chamber all of these monitors
will display the current location of
scp-4885
the foundation has kept a gps tracking
device implanted within waldo but this
information is normally kept secret to
avoid any containment breaches the
d-class essentially acts as bait for
waldo forcibly given the knowledge of
his location so that
scp-4885 will consider them a target as
part of the next phase of containment
foundation staff will wait giving waldo
enough time to arrive in the containment
chamber and dispatch the d-class within
after this all of the 36 containment
chambers are transported to random
foundation sites and disguised trucks so
that no one is sure where scp-4885
ends up every time scp-4885
breaches containment the entire
procedure has to be repeated the
foundation first encountered scp-4885
a number of years ago inside a small
wooden house the exact location of which
has since been expunged from all the scp
foundation's records while on assignment
to secure an entirely different anomaly
the foundation's mobile task force chai
19 also codenamed unrelenting punishment
were the first to discover waldo the
three-person unit consisted of
foundation operatives named amelia
merrick james klein and kurt stahl the
trio cautiously entered the wooden house
where they were meant to investigate
reports of an anomalous inanimate object
a pair of black spectacles according to
initial intelligence gathered by the scp
foundation these glasses were capable of
killing anyone that tried to wear them
leaving their body covered in pictures
like those found in the children's book
sounds familiar doesn't it it is unknown
if these black spectacles are the same
eyewear worn by scp-4885
but it doesn't seem like too far of a
leap to assume that this may well have
been the case searching the ground floor
of the team had found no sign of the
object they had been sent to recover as
amelia kurt and james made their way
upstairs something began making scraping
sounds beneath them but none of them
noticed in an abandoned bedroom on the
upstairs floor of the house kurt spotted
a drawing on the wall which looked to
have been made using crayons he took a
photo of the illustration and this image
is still kept in the foundation's
database it appears to be a child's
drawing depicting
scp-4885 wearing his signature striped
shirt and hat with empty vacant eyes
next to it was scrawled one simple
phrase waldo found mommy continuing
their way through the house the team
located the glasses they were looking
for in an upstairs bathroom however as
james bagged up the spectacles ready for
transport back to the foundation kurt
spotted another inscription on the
nearby wall one that the team were
certain hadn't been there when they had
arrived james stepped in to translate
using the foundation standard issue
translation device the phrase on the
wall read the basement the corpses from
a child's book are in the basement he is
there too
for and we're sure that you can already
guess what happened after that
immediately after reading these words
james began to groan and clutched at his
stomach showing signs of extreme pain
before amelia or kurt had any chance to
figure out what was happening to their
squad mate fingers began protruding from
james's mouth they gripped his jaw and
pulled it apart with enough force to
send his jawbone flying across the room
scp-4885 climbed its way out of james's
body and amelia and kurt both opened
fire on the creature waldow did not
react seemingly unfazed by the gunfire
and sustaining no damage as he
approached emilia who would be his next
victim
shoving his fingers into her throat
waldow wrenched apart amelia's jaw
breaking it before he clawed his way
into her mouth as he watched in horror
kurt made a panicked call for help to
the foundation but it was too late waldo
had already dispatched both james and
amelia and now kurt was about to pay the
same terrible price ever since this
incident the foundation believes that
they have
scp-4885 contained when his file was
created their researchers created an
automated algorithm designed to wipe
away any mention of
scp-4885's current location or the house
he was discovered in from foundation
records with
scp-4885 now assumed to be contained
that only leaves one question the same
burning inquiry that's been plaguing man
for decades where's waldo in this case
maybe it's safer if you didn't know
now check out the lost scp scp-000
and
scp-5049 the skin salesman demon dan's
discount homunculus depot for more of
the foundation's strangest anomalies